Hello, listener. I'm glad you found us. My name is Jason. Hey, listen. I'm joined by, hello. This is where you announce yourself. Sean Hayes. Sean, be more assertive about it. Make them, get them excited to meet you. I'm Sean Hayes. Will, tell them who you are. My name is Will Arnett, and I'm originally from Toronto, and we're doing a podcast, and we're having a lot of fun with my friends. So, come on and join us with your ears. Oh, God. Welcome to Smart Less. Smart Less.
Smart Less. Smart Less. Hey, you know how I always like to start out with a little story. Oh, sorry. Did you prepare today? You must have been too fast. I didn't, I didn't really prepare. I just... He's got chatter. No, well, first of all, I missed last night. Did I miss anything major? We missed you. That's sweet. Listener, usually the three of us get together on Sunday nights over at a friend's house,
and Sean has family in town this weekend, so he did not join us when you were missed. That is correct. So, yeah, they left this morning. That was sad to see them go, but yeah, that's why I couldn't go last. That was just too many people. It was too chaotic, and it was, nobody just wanted to like chill out here, so nobody wanted to get up and... How did that chill out go? Yeah, it was a nice... Was it a good chill out? Good. Well, I tried to get...
I introduced two of my nieces to one of my favorite movies, Tootsie, and they wanted nothing to do with it. Really? Yeah. You know what? It's really depressing. It's such a good show. I showed some stuff to Franny, my 15-year-old, and she just... It's just not... Nothing's any good. I know, because it's got to be like louder, faster, funnier.
I tried to... I tried Fletch last year, and they were kind of like, yeah. And I was like, oh, really? This is in all time. Yeah, I know. No, I get it. Like, try Stripes or something like that, or meatballs, and it's just... It's just doesn't work anymore. I don't know why. It's still funny. Well, I mean, Sean, you had his attention at meatballs.
Always. By the way, you think... Will, for the second day in a row, I'm not kidding. I had leftover spaghetti and another tuna fish sandwich. It's always in a row. When are you going to turn into 375? I'm on my way. But wait, I did want to say this. So, as you know, you saw, I got this new electric car, right?
Yeah. And it's an Audi. It's really great. You barely press on the... You know, it's not gas. It's an accelerator. Yeah, the accelerator. You just fucking go like a roller coaster. But so, we have this, as you know, this tiny gate in front of our house that I'm looking at right now.
And it's kind of unnecessary. By the way, I've been meaning to say this for a few years. I'm not kidding. Your gate is so unnecessary. It's like knee height, right? So dumb. It only goes up to the knees. 375. Your gate is the dumbest.
It is dumb. It is so dumb. But you could hop over it, but whatever, you guys know that. A doxon could hop over it. Exactly. It's true. A little hot dog dog. So, wait. So, the gate... So, when you pull up to it, the gate opens automatically. Stop calling it a gate.
Okay. The door, the trap opens up. And it stays open for like a minute or so, right? Okay. So, for some reason, Scotty, I think for security reasons, I don't know. He recalibrated it to only open for 10 seconds. This is true. And so, I don't know for security or whatever.
So, I'm pulling out of my driveway yesterday and the gate opens. And just as I'm about to leave, I forgot my phone. So, I stopped the car. I jump out and I'm heading back in the house. I hear... It completely scraped the entire side of my car. Of the new car? Of the brand new car.
No. Fucking Scotty. Yeah, I know. That's it. That was the last one. By the way, I just... I don't want to blame Scotty for this. This is what he's spending his time doing. Recalibrating the knee-high gate?
Well, listen. You get one too many hot dogs in there and... You did. You guys got one stuck over route by doxons, right? Didn't you have an attack of doxons? A pack of them surrounded the house. It's just a corgi. It's the caravan of corgis.
Oh, Sean, that's a bummer. I know, but... And then... Are you going to fix it or are you going to just drive around with it? Yeah, he changed it back. He was like... Because it happened... No, the car.
No, no, no. We're going to change the gate to stay open for a little bit. But that was like a couple of days ago and then the next day, I literally was pulling out and some guy was standing on the sidewalk and I couldn't move fast enough. And I was like freaking out. I was like, oh my God, I have like three seconds. So I gunned it backwards.
And then I was like, Scott, he's like, what's the problem? I'm like, it can't fucking... It's got to fucking stay open longer than... So he put it back. Why don't you... You don't have like an eye on there that can sense... Yes, but it's on the other side. It's on the other side.
It's on the... What is happening at your house, Sean? This thing... This is a disaster. By the way, nobody's going to be more upset about the dented car than the valet guys at Koi. They're going to be so... We went there last night.
Of course. Did you really? Of course. My sister loves it. Tracy loves it. Sean, what happened? I know. And then I was like, you guys, I didn't...
I left it totally normal and you guys banged it up. All right. So let's get to our guest. This man, guys, I'm so excited. He's an icon. He really is an icon. He's responsible for many, many of the laughs you've experienced throughout your life.
Jerry Lewis. That's right. He's actually... I've been looking to blame somebody for my laugh. So I'm glad. He's actually from Los Angeles, which I keep forgetting, but he really kind of grew up in New York.
One of his earliest jobs was an assistant stage manager for a play adaptation of the novella Breakfast at Tiffany's. Let's just say that production didn't rocket him into success immediately, but it did, however, introduce him to Mary Tyler Moore, which would prove to be very valuable later. He continued as a stage manager and then went on directing plays.
This is Jimmy Burroughs. And then years later... This is Jimmy Burroughs. He created this little thing called Cheers. Anyway, he's a legend. Everyone knows his name. He referred to him as my television father. He's directed every episode.
No, he's mine. You can't have him. He's mine. It's not other than my dad, who didn't leave me, James Bond. Oh, listener, you're in for a treat. Well, there he is. Jimmy!
Oh, look at Jimmy. Oh, my God. Was that... He just put tape on his nose. I can't believe three of my actors. Yeah. Well, I'm sorry. Actors in quotes.
That's exactly right. What's our... What's my nickname is? Batehound. And Sean's nickname is... B-story. B. Shawnee.
Or Shawnee. Or Shawnee. Shawnee. Shawnee. And what does Will have one? Willie. Willie. Sweet, sweet Willie.
What was yours, Jason? What is yours, Jason? Batehound. I don't know where it came from, but I love it. I don't know either. There's only two people who have hound. You and Courtney Cox. She's Corthound.
Corthound. Is she really? That's hysterical. Yeah. Yeah. I wanted to mention it at the end too, but I wanted to enter. But I wanted to mention it now as well. Spit it out, honey.
I know. Sorry, I'm nervous. Oh, my God. Come through the door. It's like... Come through the door. I'm so nervous. I'm so excited.
You have this new gigantic book that's out now that's called Directed by James Perot's five decades of stories from the legendary director of Taxi, Cheers, Frasier, Friends, Will and Grace, and tons more... Chicago Sons. Chicago Sons. Is Chicago Sons in there too? Yeah.
Chicago Sons is mentioned. Yes. What's Chicago Sons? Chicago Sons is this little sprint I did with D.D.P. Yomafit and David Krumholz. Paula Marshall, who was your love interest. Paula Marshall, the greatest. Wow.
I remember that show. Yeah. It was on for half a season on NBC, right? Yeah. We played three brothers that lived right behind Wrigley Field. Yes. And we had a beautiful translate on that, didn't we? Yes.
Absolutely. So, go ahead, Sean. You're going to tell the listener how lucky they are to be listening. This is so incredible. Right. Right. That is exactly what I was going to do. So, you know, I know so many things about you.
We all have known you, worked with you, loved you for a very long time. We've spent much time over the years socially and professionally. I consider you family. But what I'm excited about today is I get to ask you questions that if I was at your house, you're asking them. You'd probably tell me to shut the hell up. Now I get to corner you. So, we all know so many things about you.
You've never been at my house. Yeah. You haven't been at the nice one. I never make it past that gate. That's an actual gate. No, I know so many things about you. But my sister Tracy doesn't, which means other people may not know. But all the shows that you've sprinkled your kind of magic dust on
and made hits by directing them. I mentioned them some of them already. I tell you, more taxi chairs, Will and Grace worth mentioning again. The Hogan family, Frazier, Two and a Half Men, The Big Bang, Therian, on and on. And Sidebar, you own a lot of that part of those shows. So, I want to start out with the fact that it blows people's minds when I reveal to them not only all you've accomplished in your life, but I also love seeing them light up when I mentioned your father was a boroughs
who amongst many other great things wrote Guys and Dolls, won the Pulitzer Prize for how to succeed in business without really trying. Both massive, gigantic, massive hits on Broadway. Your father was so deeply rooted in show business from radio to theater to television. What was that like for you? Was it kid to be surrounded by all that? Like, was it thrilling for you? Or was it kind of like just what dad did?
So, you felt you needed to do it or did you want to do it? Wow, Sean, this is the first time you've learned a monologue and said it perfectly. Without cards. I had a stopper. I had a time stopper. All the hand gestures were there. Don't worry about it. He was my father, so this was my father's business. He would write on a yellow legal pad when he wrote and he would go put on a suit and a tie to direct.
And a trilby hat. He had a hat on and he would go down and he would trundle my sister and I occasionally down there and we would kind of, you know, sit in the back. I didn't had no idea what was going on. Not a clue. How old were you like when you first were like, wow, this is... When I first went, I saw Guys and Dolls when I was 11. That was 1951.
So, I remember seeing that. That was the first show I had seen that my father did. I had seen before my mom took me to, see, where's Charlie. I mean, I know you guys were not born yet. When these were up on Broadway and I'm not sure you're all born still. I'm still cooking. Yeah, I know. So, I had no, I had no desire to go into show business
because my dad was a legend in New York City. That's why. And there was just no way I was going to be in the theater at all. It was just too daunting. And then what happened? Yeah, what did you think you were going to do? Well, I was a government major at Oberlin College. Really?
Yeah. My thesis was on gerrymandering. Really? How about that? Yeah. We could use you now. I know. No, we figured it all out now.
Yeah. It's all fixed. Yeah, we got it done. Wow. And then when I graduated Oberlin, it was the Vietnam War time. So, I applied to the Yale School of Drama to kind of defer, because we all had to take physicals. You could defer your physical.
At 21, I went to the Yale School of Drama for three years. To be an actor? No, no. I was a playwright, believe it or not. Wow. Wow. You know, me who would sacrifice any character for a joke. Yeah.
But, Jimmy, I don't think my character would shut up. It's funny. Yeah. Yeah. Go faster. Yeah. Exactly. Then I had a class in directing with a professor named Nico Sacropolis,
who founded the Williamstown Theater. And he kind of showed me what directing was. I had no idea, because I watched my father and I had just no idea. And after I got out of Yale School of Drama, I did have to go take a physical, which I failed, which was lucky enough for the U.S. Army. And then... What was wrong with you?
I was too funny. You're going to distract the troops. Get them out of here. Yeah, I was going to make them laugh instead of make them shoot, I think. And then so I started working in the business. I started driving a truck on a summer tour, a summer stock tour that went to the different music tents. I would load the scenery at the end of the performance on Saturday night
and drive it so they could open the show in a new venue on Monday night. And then I stage-managed for a bit and then directed in summer stock. And then I had one point, wrote a letter to Mary Tyler Moore. Yeah, what was your first TV directing gig? The Mary Tyler Moore Show in 1974. And how many seasons were they into that by then? That was the fourth season. So when they taught you...
You wrote a letter... Let's back up to Jason's line. Okay. Directing the podcast. When you're at Yale and you took the directing class, when you didn't know what directing was, what did they teach you that directing was? What did you come out of there with like the basic of like,
oh, that's what they do for Tracy? You know, I had no idea what a director did, literally. You know, my mind was elsewhere when I was watching my dad. He wrote and directed at the same time. So, you know, he would chatter and everything like that. But then I kind of got it because I was in a couple of productions at Yale as a supernumerary in the background. And there was, you know, crafting how it looked and everything like that.
But what would you say if Tracy, Sean's sister, said, well, what does a director do? What do you do to help, you know, it all happen? Well, I'd like to think of myself as a guy in a lifeboat with a group of people with me. And I'm kind of the captain of the lifeboat. And it's my job to get a performance in that lifeboat of the show with the emotions of the characters plus the laughs.
And, you know, letting people realize that I will protect them in the lifeboat. The way I am, as you guys know, is I'm not a Martinette. I'm kind of a nice, sweet guy who happens to be funny. And I like to have all the actors behave that way and all the actors react that way and be in this lifeboat together with me. And because we're all in this boat, we're all rowing.
And so I kind of got that from watching Nico. So he was much more concerned with how it looked and where extra supernumeraries had to be and everything like that. But when he worked with the actors, I kind of saw the light. Well, it's interesting too, because how old were you when you were stage manager on Broadway? 26.
Wow. So at that point, you've been around like nutty actors and actresses your entire life. You must have honed your skills pretty early and how to communicate with them and know what their needs are and knowing how to quiet down the crazy or whatever, right? I guess so. I was a stage manager on Breakfast at Tiffany's,
which you mentioned, which had Mary Tyler Moore, Richard Chamberlain, and Sally Kellerman, who were three actors from California that were doing their first Broadway show. Wow, that's crazy. And I was in charge of them. In other words, I had to make sure that they knew what side of the stage to enter during a performance,
where to come off. I made sure they had lunch. I made sure they had dinner. I made sure they were on time. I was literally their shepherd. And so again, I wasn't involved emotionally in how the show was shaped or anything like that. I was just responsible for those three people
and making their life easier. And I'm a kind of nice guy. So they liked me and I liked them. And luckily enough, as I said, one of the stars was Mary Tyler Moore, and that just led to my career. Wow. So when you go into directing multi-camera television,
which for the listener, that's the stuff in front of a live audience and you hear the laughter and all that stuff. So it is basically, you could be described as filmed theater. Did you approach it as that, like your love for theater? Did you just kind of start directing these things as just, well, we're just going to film this stage production since it's all kind of proscenium.
Or did you incorporate the camera into it all and created something different? It was all about filming a play. I spent five months learning the cameras. I sat in stands and watched my mentor, Jay Sandrich, and Alan Raffkin, and Peter Bonners was directing then. And I watched Michael Zinberg. Peter Bonners was directing before you?
Oh, yeah. He was directed on the Newhart show. Wow. And wasn't it true, Jimmy, that they used to do all, you have three cameras, and you were one of the first, if not the first, to add a fourth camera? Yeah. We, Mary and Newhart, they used three cameras,
and Rhoda and Paul Sand, they all had three cameras, except if the show had an order amount of people and then they brought a fourth camera in. But Taxi was really the first show to have four cameras permanently because they were all rolling film. Four cameras rolling film simultaneously gets expensive. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because you use one shot from one camera at any one moment.
And then when digital cards came out, it became a lot easier to go back and reshoot and everything like that. But you didn't have monitors back then either for a long time. No. When did the monitor first come in that you could actually see what you were shooting?
Before cameras were shooting. That wasn't till like the late 80s, early 90s. No, even on tape shows. When I did the Betty White show, believe it or not, this is when she was an actress with John Hillerman, and she, Charlie Seifer, who played her stunt double, there was a series created at MTM. And they had video cameras, so I had four video monitors.
Okay. But I didn't have film until like the sixth or seventh year of Cheers. There were no film. They hadn't figured out how to put a monitor in a film camera. So you're standing on the floor watching all the cameras in it. And again, like Jason says, just for Tracy, most comedy, TV comedies, or what we call a single camera, which look more like a movie.
And you know, like The Office or whatever, all these kinds of shows. You break the fourth wall. Yeah. But the shows that we're talking about that have these multi-cams are all the great classic shows, like Cheers and Seinfeld and Friends. And the camera never gets up into the set. Right.
And of course, every time you mention any of these shows, most of them are Jimmy directed, at least the whole series or the pilot. It's freaking crazy. And so you're down there on the floor, my recollection, even once you had monitors, I mean, Jimmy, on tape nights, you're never standing in front of the monitor.
You're standing on the floor next to the cameras, walking back and forth between the cameras, kicking cameras in one direction. Yeah, imagining what they're seeing. There's no proof because there were no monitors. There were no monitors. But you could tell if one of those film cameras is kind of pointed down a little bit.
You know, they're in a wide shot. If it's up, you know, they're in a tight shot because they are more level with the actor's face. So I could kind of tell that. But for me, being with my actors was more important than if I missed a shot. It was important for me on any show I do, and I still do it.
I never go to Video Village. Video Village is where all the monitors are, where all the writers and they hang out outside a shot. They watch these monitors, and they're the first to tell you when they see a boom shadow or anything like that. But I'm always, you know, be it the Millers or Chicago Sons or Will and Grace,
I'm always on the floor with my actors because to me, they're my cherished human beings. So, but I can, you know, and sometimes I don't watch them because they're mugging too much, but I always will listen. I'll always listen to the dialogue. And I will always try if an actor on the way to a joke
screws up the line. I will always jump in and scream, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup. So that the audience doesn't hear the joke the wrong way because humor is 90% surprise, and if they hear it the right way, the laugh will be three times as large. Yeah, let me explain that again for Tracy. Just to be clear, there's such an interesting thing,
and I remember experiencing firsthand the first time, and it's such a joy. Would be you're doing a scene, and then you, you know, I go up or somebody goes up and there's like a little bit of a flub, and Jimmy can tell that the, it's right before the joke is coming in the punchline, and he can tell that the audience isn't going to get
the full effect of the joke, and Jimmy will jump in and full audience will go, stop, stop, stop. And everybody stops, and the audience is like, what the stop? Well, you can also tell that the actor's about to lose it. About to lose it, right? Yeah, yeah. And you guys all know that feeling of, you've been there with Jimmy doing that.
Yeah, the first time I was like 28 years old, and I'm like about to screw up a line, I'm like, what did I, what the fuck did I do? Did I do something wrong? I thought I was in so much trouble. And what he's doing is he's protecting the audience, and he's protecting you. He's giving you a chance to get it right the first time, and Jimmy, you're so right.
I'm such a big proponent of that too. So much of comedy is surprise, and the people who make all of us laugh are people who have that element of surprise that you'd never know what they're going to say. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
You know, you once said to me a long time ago, about making hit TV show, you said, it's actually really simple. You just got to hire funny people, period. And I kind of blown away by that. And so why do you think that that's so easy to say, but so hard for networks and studios to execute? Because there are only so many funny people.
That's interesting. Well, but what would you rather have a perfect sitcom script? In other words, all the jokes are like just bulletproof. Like anybody can get a laugh at these. Or would you rather have kind of like a double, right? Not a home run, but actors that can perform funny. They can create characters that are just kind of entertaining and fun to watch anyway,
and then the fun dialogue is kind of a plus. Like, do you know what I mean? What is more valuable? A great script or great actors? I guess that's correct. Well, to start with a great script, a great script is more valuable. But bad actors can screw that up, right?
Yeah, but hopefully that doesn't happen. You know, there's a few times in my career where I've read perfect scripts, like Cheers was unbelievable. The friend script, literally the friend script, 95% of what was on the page that I read is on that screen. For the pilot of friends. For the pilot of friends, and Will and Grace.
And, you know, I want to take a great script and make it better. I can take a good script and make it very good, but that's smoke and mirrors. You need to be lucky enough to have a great script, a great cast, and the right time slot. Speaking of a great cast, Jimmy, I want you to, I remember you've told this story before, we all know, but you did the friend's pilot.
God, I remember that pilot. I don't know if you guys do. I remember reading that pilot in New York and going in and auditioning for it and not being called that. Did you get it? I'm waiting. I did change numbers, so there's a chance. I killed you.
Jimmy killed me. He got my tape and he threw it in the trash. Yeah, yeah. You were not right for Rachel. I was not. But I could have had a signature haircut. But anyway, so, Jimmy, you do that pilot, like you said, 95% is out there,
and you had the perfect cast for the perfect show. And I remember you telling me this story about, you took them to Vegas, right? Yeah. What was that story? In the third week or the fourth week, I went to Warner Brothers and I said, I think this show is really special.
Can you give me the plane to take these six people to Las Vegas? I want to take them to dinner. They were reluctant to give me the plane, so we walked. So they did give me the plane. I took them to Vegas. I took them to dinner at Spago in Cesar Palace. We had a big round table. I was there with the six of them, all greenhorns,
a little experience here and there. Swimmer had done a Monty before, and J.A. was in, she was in Muddling Through, and Courtney had been on Family Ties, but really kind of green. And I literally said, and I know it was incredibly prophetic, but I had no idea at the time, I said, this trip to Vegas, walking around this casino,
is your last shot at anonymity. You will never be able to walk through a casino or anywhere without being mauled. Wow. It's 100% true. And then they had no money, so I gave each $200, and they gambled, and we had a great time, we came back,
and the rest is history. Yeah, they turned it into 500 million. Wow. Those are good odds they had. I'm sidebar, right, just sidebar Vegas story. Jimmy knew my mom, and I took her to this really, really, really fancy restaurant in Vegas one time, and she always kind of had thought,
she had to put on airs when we were around, because we didn't grow up with any money, so we were at this really fancy restaurant, and the waiter comes by, he's in a tuxedo, and he goes, and she had her friends there with her too, and the waiter goes, can I start you off with something to drink? And she goes, I'll have a white Zinfandel, please.
And he goes, okay, and he's just about to walk away. She goes, excuse me, he goes, yeah, she goes, can you put some ice in that, please? It was like a five-star restaurant. I was like, an ice and a white Zinfandel. But anyway, that's such a cool story. I miss your mom, honey. I know me too.
I don't know where she is, she hasn't returned my calls. You should keep an eye on her. Oh, Will. Oh, somebody moved the bar down. Somebody lowered the bar. I'm just saying. But wait a minute. Back of us take insistence.
Jimmy, back up. You did that with us too, by the way, which was so great. You took us to San Francisco at the beginning of Will and Grace. How do you know? How do you know before anybody else knows? Yeah, you never took me anywhere
on any of the shows you did that I was in. He must have smelled something. Think of the show, honey. You were 15 on the Hogan family. So where are we going to go? Chuck E. Cheese. I think it had driven me out to Laughlin or something. That hysterical.
But you know, Jimmy, also you told me once, when you got the script for Cheers, and you tell me, I'm going to get it wrong, so please just jump in. But I think you said something like, you called the Charles brothers who wrote it and you said, thank you for bringing radio to TV, meaning it was all about the words.
You almost didn't even have to look at it because it was so well written or something like that. That's exactly my quote. I said, you brought radio back to television. Which one was this? Cheers. Cheers. But you'd known them, you'd met them on taxi, yeah?
We met on taxi, yeah. When we came up with the idea of a bar, we spent a lot of time in bars just researching. And we would sit and we'd order, believe it or not, I ordered a Weiss and Vintel with ice. Sure, of course. It's incredibly ironic. Yeah, it's not ironic.
I do believe it turns out it's a very popular drink. And we would sit there and we would just listen. You know, they had no idea who we were. And so all that stuff, in fact, in the pilot, what's the sweatiest movie ever made, that run comes from when we were in our office outside the Paramount Commissary, we heard two people talking about the sweatiest movie ever made.
The sweatiest movie. Yeah, yeah. So, you know, it was, are you joined? You asked me how I know? Yeah. I don't know. Well, it seems like you do. I knew from the run through of Cheers how good that show would be
最让人捏一把汗的电影。是啊，是啊。所以，你知道，这，你加入了？你问我怎么知道的？是啊。我不知道。好吧，听起来你确实知道。我从《干杯酒吧》的彩排中就知道那部剧会有多棒
because we always did a run through. On all my shows, we do an audience run through three days before we shoot. Just to see if we got a piece of shit or we got a piece of turd. And the audience comes in, you know, I have one camera covering the action. We did it on the Millers.
因为我们总是做彩排。在我的所有节目中，我们都会在拍摄前三天进行一次观众彩排。只是为了看看我们拍的是个烂摊子还是个一文不值的东西。观众进来了，你知道的，我用一台摄像机记录全过程。我们在《米勒一家》上也这么做了。
We did it on Chicago Sons. And from that, you get a sense of what the audience is going to react to. And I remember on Cheers, when Georgie went entered and people at Norm and Sam said, what do you know? And Norm said, not enough. It was never written as a joke. Oh, really? No, it was not a joke.
我们在《芝加哥之子》上也这么做了。从中，你能感受到观众会有什么反应。我记得在《干杯酒吧》里，当乔治登场时，诺姆和萨姆说，你知道些什么？诺姆说，知道得还不够。这句台词从来都不是作为笑话写的。哦，真的吗？不，这不是个笑话。
Hey, what do you know? Not enough? That's a story. Not enough. And because of the person saying it and how he looked and a guy like that in a bar, it all gelled to become this huge laugh and made the writer's life miserable
嘿，你知道些什么？知道得还不够？这是一个梗。不够。因为说这句话的人以及他的外表，还有酒吧里那种类型的家伙，这一切完美融合，变成了一个巨大的笑声，并让编剧的生活苦不堪言
because every time he entered, they had to come up with a new norm issue. You're right, of course. How much of, when you're casting these incredible ensembles like Friends or Cheers and the other shows that you've done, I mean, your batting average must be incredible. And how do you know, do you know, when you see someone like George Wendt come in,
因为每次他登场，他们都必须想出一个新的诺姆梗。你说得对，当然。当你为《老友记》或《干杯酒吧》以及你做过的其他节目挑选这些不可思议的演员阵容时，你在其中投入了多少，我的意思是，你的成功率一定高得惊人。你怎么知道，当你看到像乔治·温特这样的人走进来时，你知道吗，
are you making a calculation that, OK, I know the dialogue, this guy's going to have to say, the combination of his, how he comes across, what his natural sort of communication thing is, with these, like, is it that? Are you trying to figure out a puzzle there? Or are you just going on instinct? Oh, this is a great guy.
你在做这样的计算吗，好吧，我知道这些台词，这家伙得说这些，他的外表、他自然的交流方式与这些结合在一起，是这样的吗？你在那儿琢磨一个谜题吗？还是全凭直觉？哦，这是个好家伙。
He's funny. It'll work. Well, the way the character of Norm was written, George is the perfect person to play that. He looks like he's had a few beers. He never gets off of bar stool. He's dry, which that character was. So, again, we took something, a great part,
他很搞笑。这行得通。好吧，就诺姆这个角色的剧本而言，乔治是扮演这个角色的不二人选。他看起来像喝了几杯。他从不离开酒吧高脚凳。他很冷幽默，这个角色就是这样。所以，再次说明，我们拿到了一个好剧本，
put a great actor in it, and it took off. You take a great part and put a kind of good actor in it. It's not going to be as effective. He must have loved his blocking, George Wendt. Oh, my God. He's like where he stands and sits and stuff. All he did was sit on the chair. Did he at any point say, all right,
找了一个优秀的演员来演，然后就火了。你拿一个好剧本，找一个马马虎虎的演员来演。效果就不会那么好。他一定很喜欢他的走位，乔治·温特。哦，天哪。他就像他站着、坐着之类的那样。他唯一做的就是坐在椅子上。他有没有在哪个时刻说，好吧，
it looks like I'm going to be sitting on this bar stool for a long time. Paul. Did he ever talk to the set dressers or anything about making that seat a little bit cushier or a little bit more support? Or did he ever, did him or John Ratzenberg ever get involved with any of that stuff?
看来我要在这个酒吧高脚凳上坐很长时间了。保罗。他有没有跟布景师或者任何人谈过，把那个座位弄得更舒服一点，或者更有支撑力一点？或者他有没有，他和约翰·拉岑贝格有没有参与过任何这类事情？
No, George said he could file, if he had hemorrhoids, it would be, he could get paid. Your fault. By the way, George Wendt, Jason Sudeik, his uncle. I know. Oh, that's great. His mom's brother. That's amazing.
不，乔治说他可以申请，如果他有痔疮的话，就可以，他可以拿到赔偿。你的错。顺便说一句，乔治·温特，杰森·苏戴奇斯的叔叔。我知道。哦，太棒了。他妈妈的弟弟。太神奇了。
Yeah, it's, you know, George, he was, he was great. And in the book, I talk about the fact that Norm's seat where he sat, he's got a long haul to get to that seat. Yeah. Normally, he would walk in the bar and I would put him in the seat, the first seat he came to, but the fact was Diane was there in the show. She enters and she has to be there closer to the door
是啊，你知道，乔治，他，他很棒。在书中，我谈到了诺姆坐的那个座位，他要走到那个座位得走好长一段路。是啊。通常情况下，他走进酒吧，我会让他坐在他遇到的第一个座位上，但事实是黛安在剧中。她登场了，她必须离门更近一些
because she's waiting for her, her fiance to come with the ring. So it forced me to take George all the way across. So it made the Normisms have to be a little longer. And so to get him around there. But it ended up being such an important part of that character because every time you see him kind of Exhaustingly kind of shuffle in, it just sets up. It's like this declaration.
因为她在等她，她的未婚夫带着戒指来。这就迫使我让乔治走过整个大厅。所以这使得诺姆的那些经典台词必须稍微长一点。为了让他绕过去。但结果这成了那个角色如此重要的一部分，因为每次你看到他那种精疲力竭、步履蹒跚地走进来，这就奠定了基调。这就像是一个宣言。
But isn't that amazing? Like it's almost like Jason goes back to your original question. Like, what would you say, like, what do you do? What is directing? Well, here you've got, you've got a puzzle, right? You've got to bring, you've got an actor who's sitting on one end, you've got to bring another actor in,
但这不是太神奇了吗？就像杰森回到了你最初的问题。就像，你会说，你会做什么？什么是导演？好吧，这里你有一个谜题，对吧？你必须把，你有一个坐在边缘的演员，你必须带另一个演员进来，
and you got to figure out a way to make it interesting and funny and on story and bring him across and get him into a different spot. It's a lot of shit to think about. Willie on the pilot of the Millers. The most important thing for me was in that scene between your mother and father. You know, when they're talking about sex, that whole thing.
你必须想办法让它变得有趣、搞笑、符合剧情，让他走过来，把他带到一个不同的位置。有太多破事要想了。威利，在《米勒一家》的试播集中。对最重要的事是，在你母亲和父亲之间的那场戏里。你知道，当他们在谈论性的时候，整段过程。
Yeah. Was to put you in the middle. Yeah. Do you remember that? I sure do. Yeah, of course. Yeah, because that's where the reactions have to be. Yeah.
是啊。就是把你放在中间。是啊。你还记得吗？我当然记得。是啊，当然。是啊，因为那是必须做出反应的地方。是啊。
It's not funny. It's not funny if they're both in one, if they're on both on one side of the stage and you're on the other side because you're reacting only one way. So to figure out that puzzle, it was, you know, it was obvious to me that you had to be in the middle from your fault between your father and your mother because that's where the laughs were.
这并不好笑。如果他们俩都在一侧，如果他们都在舞台的一侧而你在另一侧，那就不好笑了，因为你只能做出单向的反应。所以为了破解这个谜题，你知道，对我来说显而易见的是，你必须坐在你父亲和你母亲之间的中间位置，因为笑点都在那里。
I know. And it was, you were so friggin' funny in that moment. Oh, thank you. You were, God. I love that. But then there's another puzzle you got to figure out with the wing cameras there. If he's in the middle and they're book-ending him,
我知道。而且在那一刻，你真是搞笑得要命。哦，谢谢你。真的，天哪。我太喜欢了。但接着你还得用侧面摄像机解决另一个谜题。如果他在中间，而他们夹在他两旁，
you don't want him jump. You don't want him in both two shots, right? So like, you got to decide who's going to be in the single, who's going to be in the two-shot. Like, your work doesn't stop. Well, there were three singles there because they were far enough apart. Oh, okay.
你可不想让他跳戏。你不想让他同时出现在两个双人镜头里，对吧？所以就像，你得决定谁拍单人镜头，谁拍双人镜头。你的工作永远不会停止。好吧，那里有三个单人镜头，因为他们离得够远。哦，好吧。
Wow. That was the greatest thrill for me. So I was under contract doing a show at NBC. And then my agent said, I wasn't really supposed to take a meeting with Jimmy and Greg Garcia, our friend, the great Greg Garcia, who I loved to death. And so they said,
哇。对我来说那是最大的激动。所以当时我正与NBC签约拍一部剧。然后我的经纪人说，我本不该和吉米以及格雷格·加西亚开会的，我们的朋友，伟大的格雷格·加西亚，我爱死他了。所以他们说，
well, Greg Garcia and Jimmy Burroughs might be at our office. And if you run into them there, it's not a meeting. And I said, that's true. So they literally like told me what office they were in. And then I just had, it was kind of like all, and then we talked about doing the millers. And that's how that went down. And I was, it was such a thrill, thrill, thrill for me, man.
好吧，格雷格·加西亚和吉米·伯罗斯可能会在我们的办公室。如果你在那儿碰巧遇到他们，那可不算是一场会议。我说，那倒也是。所以他们真的就像是告诉我他们在哪个办公室。然后我只有，就好像一切都在那儿，接着我们谈了谈拍《米勒一家》的事。事情就是这样发展的。对我来说，那真是太激动、激动、激动了，老兄。
You know, I remember Jimmy in the pilot of Will and Grace since we're talking about pilots. I have come at my character, Jack comes in with a bird cage and all this luggage. Guapo. Guapo. Oh my God. I didn't even remember that.
你知道的，我记得吉米在《威尔与格蕾丝》的试播集中，既然我们在谈论试播集。我带着我的角色，杰克带着一个鸟笼和所有的行李登场了。瓜波。瓜波。哦，天哪。我甚至都不记得那个了。
I know it's intense. But I, so I come in with this bird cage covered. It's covered bird cage and luggage. And I keep, the joke is it's a runner through the pilot where I'm going to keep moving in and Will says, not tonight, not tonight. I'm like, God, okay, come back tomorrow, whatever the thing is. And Jimmy said, and when I got really upset with Will,
我知道这很强烈。但，所以我带着这个盖着的鸟笼进来了。是个盖着的鸟笼和行李。我一直，笑点是一个贯穿试播集的桥段，我要一直搬进来，而威尔说，今晚不行，今晚不行。我就像，天哪，好吧，明天再来，不管是哪种情况。吉米说，当我真的对威尔生气时，
I would shake the luggage and the bird cage and I would become like very physical. And Jimmy goes, wait, stop. And he goes over to props and he goes, you got any bird feathers or anything? And the guy goes, yeah, I can, I can muster something up. He throws the bird feathers in the cage. So when I shake them, all the feathers.
我会摇晃行李和鸟笼，我会变得非常亢奋。吉米说，等等，停。他走到道具部门去，他说，你有鸟羽毛或者别的什么吗？那家伙说，有，我可以，我可以凑合弄点东西。他把鸟羽毛扔进笼子里。所以当我摇晃它们时，所有的羽毛。
Every time. Every time. Like I'm throwing the bird around. It was so funny. And then I was like, how do you think of shit like that? It was so hilarious. It will give you a prop that will make everything come together. It'll be the perfect stitch between the script
每次。每次。就像我在把那只鸟甩来甩去一样。太搞笑了。然后我就想，你怎么能想出这种破主意？太滑稽了。威尔会给你一个道具，让一切水乳交融。这将是剧本与表演之间完美的针脚
and the performance. This one little thing he'll pick up on a desk and put it in your hand and play with this when you're saying that line. Speaking of that, Mr. B, is there comedy in your future? Or is that, is that skill gone? I keep telling Jimmy, I keep saying the same thing to him.
这一个小小的事物，他会从桌上拿起来放进你手里，在你念那句台词时玩弄它。说到这个，B先生，你的未来还有喜剧吗？还是说，那个，那个技能已经消失了？我一直在告诉吉米，我一直在对他说同样的话。
Like, what are you doing? What are you doing? You're killing people. You're the funniest. You're literally killing people. Stop killing people. I'm ready. I'm ready.
就像，你在干什么？你在干什么？你在把大家逗得前仰后合。你是最搞笑的。你简直把大家都逗得笑死了。别再逗得大家笑死了。我准备好了。我准备好了。
What are you doing? I'm ready. Well, I'm ready. We've seen enough of your dark side. I know. The blue, the blue money laundering. Jimmy, you should have seen him on the 16th green today. He was so dark.
你在干什么？我准备好了。好吧，我们已经看过足够多你阴暗的一面了。我知道。那个阴郁的，洗黑钱的。吉米，你今天真该看看他在第16洞果岭上的样子。他太阴暗了。
He made me put out a two-footer. I thought he gave me the putt, and he gave it to our buddy, Dan, and I picked up and he goes, not you, and he made me go back and put it. I said, put it back down. He did. Oh, jeez.
他逼我推一个两英尺推杆。我以为他送我这个推杆了，结果他把它送给了我们的哥们儿丹，然后我把球拿起来，他说，不是你，他逼我回去重新推。我说，把它放回去。他真的照做了。哦，天哪。
And I said, I said, karma's going to get you. I said, you're going to get into a fender bender. And I said, you're going to be exchanging insurance with a guy on Beverly Glen right now. On the way home. On the way home. But Jimmy, so you do,
我说，我说了，因果报应会找上你的。我说，你会遇到一次轻微的追尾事故。我说，你现在就要在贝弗利格伦大道上和一个家伙交换保险信息了。在回家的路上。在回家的路上。但是吉米，所以你做，
I mean, there's so many great things. I feel like we're all over. I know. I love stories. I just love all your stories. The best stories. Tell me just like Ted Danson wasn't supposed to get the part in Shears, right?
我是说，有那么多棒极了的事情。我觉得我们无所不谈。我知道。我喜欢故事。我只是喜欢你所有的故事。最棒的故事。告诉我，比如特德·丹森本来不应该得到《干杯酒吧》里的角色的，对吧？
Like who had it originally? And what was that story? No, no. There was a final audition for the Diane and Sam in Shears. There were three couples, Fred Dreyer, former Los Angeles Ram, and Julia Duffy.
就像本来是谁试镜的？那是个什么样的故事？不，不。那是《干杯酒吧》中黛安和萨姆的最后一次试镜。有三对组合，弗雷德·德雷尔，前洛杉矶公羊队球员，和茱莉亚·达菲。
She was funny. Billy Devane and Lisa Eichorn. Wow. And Ted and Shelley. Bill Devane. Wow. Bill Devane. Yeah.
她很搞笑。比利·德万和丽莎·艾柯恩。哇。还有特德和谢莉。比尔·德万。哇。比尔·德万。是啊。
Well, so they were all three different. Yeah. They were all completely different. Obviously the best chemistry was Ted and Shelley. Although when we got up with the network after, two out of the 10 people wanted to hire Fred Dreyer because at that point, Sam alone was a wide receiver for the Patriots.
好吧，所以他们三个完全不同。是啊。他们完全不同。显然化学反应最好的是特德和谢莉。尽管后来我们和电视台开会时，10个人中有2个人想雇弗雷德·德雷尔，因为当时，萨姆本来是爱国者队的接球手。
Uh-huh. So we felt Freddie didn't have the skill, the comedic skills to do a full-on series. Although we brought him back as Sam's friend. So the obvious choice was Ted and Shelley. Was Tartakov still running things, or was it Warren Littlefield by then? No, it was Brandon.
嗯哼。所以我们觉得弗雷德没有那个功底，没有出演整部剧的喜剧功底。尽管我们后来让他作为萨姆的朋友回归了。所以显而易见的选择是特德和谢莉。当时塔托科夫还在掌权，还是沃伦·利特尔菲尔德已经接手了？不，是布兰登。
Brandon, when we started in, at NBC when we made a deal in 1961, Fred Silverman was running, 1981. Fred Silverman was running. By the time we came back with Cheers, Grant Tinker had taken over, and Brandon was there. And, you know, Grant hired me.
布兰登，当我们开始时，我们在1961年在NBC达成了一笔交易，弗雷德·西尔弗曼在掌权，1981年。弗雷德·西尔弗曼在掌权。当我们带着《干杯酒吧》回归时，格兰特·蒂克尔已经接管了，布兰登也在那儿。而且，你知道，格兰特雇了我。
He was the husband to Mary Terry Moore. Mary Terry Moore, yeah. And you guys, the first season, you guys were like in the bottom of the ratings the first season. Is that right? We were, on Thanksgiving, we were, there were 77 shows on the air.
他是玛丽·泰勒·摩尔的丈夫。玛丽·泰勒·摩尔，是啊。而且你们，第一季的时候，你们的收视率几乎垫底。是这样吗？我们是，在感恩节的时候，我们，当时有77部剧在播出。
We were 77th. Wow. That's crazy. I mean, the fact, by the way, at that time, there was so much pressure. If you didn't have a huge number, you'd get canceled. How did, they just knew,
我们排在第77位。哇。太疯狂了。我是说，事实上，顺便说一句，那时候压力太大了。如果你没有一个巨大的收视数字，你就会被砍掉。怎么会，他们只是知道，
I guess Brandon Tartakov just knew that it was just going to take a minute. Seinfeld had a similar start, yeah? They had nothing else. Yeah. Wow. They had nothing else. Plus, Brandon and Grant loved the show.
我猜布兰登·塔托科夫只是知道这需要一点时间。《宋飞正传》也有过类似的开局，是吧？他们别无选择。是啊。哇。他们别无选择。另外，布兰登和格兰特很喜欢这部剧。
The press loved the show. And then in the summer of our first season, once the audience, our competition was Simon and Simon. And the lead in the Simon and Simon was a Magnum PI with Tommy Selleck. So everybody watched that show. So in the summer, when they re-ran our shows,
媒体很喜欢这部剧。然后在我们第一季的夏天，一旦观众，我们的竞争对手是《西蒙与西蒙》。《西蒙与西蒙》的主演是汤姆·塞立克的《夏威夷神探》。所以每个人都在看那个节目。所以在夏天，当他们重播我们的节目时，
people started to watch us because they had already seen Simon and Simon and Magnum. Smart. So we started to take off. And then a year after that, Cosby came in and that was it. Wow. And now, a word from our sponsor.
人们开始看我们的节目，因为他们已经看过《西蒙与西蒙》和《夏威夷神探》了。聪明。所以我们开始起飞了。然后一年之后，《考斯比秀》播出了，就是这样。哇。现在，听一听我们赞助商的话。
And now, back to the show. Now, why do you think it is that there are so few multi-cam sitcoms on television today versus back then? I think at one point there were, I want to say there were like 50 multi-cam shows between the four networks. And now there's six?
现在，回到节目中。现在，你认为为什么当今电视上多机位情景喜剧比当年少得多？我想曾经有一段时间，我想说在四大电视网之间大约有50部多机位剧集。现在只有六部了？
Yeah. Yeah, probably. I mean, the audience is still there. I mean, stuff is still funny. That format is still entertaining. And why don't they give it a chance to stay on? Like, it doesn't seem like this. I have no idea.
是啊。是啊，可能吧。我是说，观众依然还在。我是说，内容依然搞笑。那个形式依然具有娱乐性。为什么他们不给它一个留存的机会呢？这看起来不像。我不知道。
You know, I've attended the death of multi-camera sitcoms many times, but I'm afraid now, I don't know what's going on. CBS has two comedies on the air. That's it. They have ghosts. And that's single-camera, isn't it? Yeah, but they have neighborhood,
你知道，我已经见证过多机位情景喜剧的消亡很多次了，但我现在恐怕，我不知道怎么回事。CBS有两部喜剧在播。就这样。他们有《鬼屋欢乐送》。那是单机位的，对吧？是的，但他们有《邻家罐头》，
which is a multi-camera. I just don't understand it. I mean, I can understand how comedies have gone away in movies because they used to offset their costs with DVDs and VHS tapes. That whole market's gone away. But like in television, the business model of it, you would think would still support it.
那是个多机位剧。我就是不理解。我是说，我能理解喜剧在电影中是如何消亡的，因为他们过去靠DVD和录像带抵消成本。整个市场已经消失了。但就像在电视领域，其商业模式，你本以为它仍然能支撑下去。
Yeah. So I just, I don't get it. I have no idea. I wonder if they just built it, they would come. Yeah, or just keep it on. Well, you need one hit. But Chuck Lorre had a ton of great hits, and that didn't open up the floodgates either.
是啊。所以我只是，我不明白。我毫无头脑。我想如果他们建成了，观众就会来。是啊，或者就让它播下去。好吧，你需要一个爆款。但查克·洛尔有过一吨伟大的爆款，也没有打开闸门啊。
People don't want to laugh anymore, Jason. People like you have been flooding them with murdering and money laundering. You killed laughter in America. Jimmy, when you did... Single-handedly. Single-handedly. Jimmy, and also on the golf course.
人们不再想笑了，杰森。像你这样的人一直在用谋杀和洗黑钱狂轰滥炸他们。你扼杀了美国的笑声。吉米，当你拍……一手造成的。一手造成的。吉米，而且在高尔夫球场上也是。
You're killing people everywhere. Jimmy, so you mentioned you were on Mary Tyler Moore, and then you went and you met the Charles brothers when you were on Taxi. Taxi was a cast that was also stacked with Colin. Andy Kaufman. Crazy real. So I was going to get to Andy Kaufman.
你到处在谋杀大家。吉米，所以你提到你演过《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀》，然后你去了《出租车》剧组遇到了查尔斯兄弟。《出租车》的演员阵容也是大牌云集。安迪·考夫曼。疯狂真实。所以我正要说到安迪·考夫曼。
I remember one time you told me about working with Andy Kaufman, and when they had to, he had a deal. What was his deal? He was allowed to have, what's his name? Tony. Tony Clifton. Tony Clifton had to be on the show, right? Okay, so explain to Tracy who Tony Clifton is.
我记得有一次你跟我讲过和安迪·考夫曼合作的事，当他们必须的时候，他有个协议。他的协议是什么？他被允许带，叫什么名字来着？托尼。托尼·克利夫顿。托尼·克利夫顿必须出现在节目中，对吧？好吧，向特雷西解释一下谁是托尼·克利夫顿。
Okay. So when I actually met the Charles brothers on the Phyllis show, so that's a little known fact, but anyway, on Taxi, Andy Kaufman was hired to play Lockett and Mechanic, but in his deal, they had to hire Tony Clifton, which was Andy's alter ego. To hire his alter ego. It's insane.
好吧。所以当我实际上在《菲利斯秀》上遇到查尔斯兄弟时，这是一个鲜为人知的事实，但不管怎样，在《出租车》上，安迪·考夫曼被雇来扮演修理工拉克特，但在他的协议中，他们必须雇佣托尼·克利夫顿，也就是安迪的另一个自我。雇佣他的另一个自我。这太疯狂了。
He had to hire his alter ego to do one episode of Taxi. I mean, did he have the juice to make that kind of outrageous demand at the time? Who was he before you guys hired him? He was the bravest comic I've ever seen in the world. Yeah. He never told a joke. Ever.
他不得不雇佣他的另一个自我来演一集《出租车》。我是说，他当时有那个分量提出那种离谱的要求吗？在你们雇他之前他是谁？他是我见过的世界上最勇敢的喜剧演员。是啊。他从来不讲笑话。从来没有。
Right. His act, he would wrestle women. That was one of his acts. He would come out. I saw him once come out, sit down in a chair and start reading Gone with the Wind until you left. He didn't care. It was three minutes.
对。他的表演，他会跟女人摔跤。那是他的表演之一。他会走出来。我曾看他走出来一次，在一把椅子上坐下，开始读《飘》，直到你离开。他不在乎。那是三分钟。
It's very, it's very Will Forte. It's crazy. So the deal was that Andy would put on the Tony Clifton suit, which was frilled shirt and a bespeckled sport coat, prosthetics on his, on his cheeks, no prosthetics on his hands, which gave him away. And he was hired to play Louis De Palma's brother on an episode of Taxi.
这非常，非常威尔·福特。太疯狂了。所以协议是安迪会穿上托尼·克利夫顿的西装，那是荷叶边衬衫和一件洒满斑点的运动夹克，他的脸颊上有假体，手上没有假体，这出卖了他。他被雇来在《出租车》的一集中扮演路易·德帕尔马的兄弟。
Danny DeVito's character. Danny DeVito's character. Yeah. What? Okay. So I come in that day for the reading. And it's today that Bucky Dent hit the home run for the Yankees to beat the Red Sox.
丹尼·德维托的角色。丹尼·德维托的角色。是啊。什么？好吧。所以那天我来参加剧本围读。就是那天巴基·登特为洋基队打出本垒打击败红袜队的日子。
And Tony and I, Tony, Danza and I are in the proper room watching this game and Andy had day night reversal. So when he would come to rehearsal, he would only come after one o'clock. So at nine in the morning we were watching this game and in walks Andy. And he said, when are we going to, he's, he's, he's got the Tony Clifton persona.
托尼和我，托尼·丹扎和我在道具室里看着这场比赛，安迪有昼夜颠倒的毛病。所以当他来排练时，他只在一点钟以后来。所以在早上九点钟我们正看着这场比赛时，安迪走了进来。他说，我们什么时候开始，他，他，他带着托尼·克利夫顿的人设。
Tony Clifton. It's not, it's, it's, hey guys, come on, when are we going to rehearse? So Tony and I look at one another. And so we go out, we start rehearsing. And he can't do it. He just, cause he's Andy Kaufman playing Tony Clifton, playing Louis De Palma's brother.
托尼·克利夫顿。不是，不是，是，嘿，伙计们，拜托，我们什么时候排练？所以托尼和我对视了一眼。然后我们出去，开始排练。而他根本演不了。他就是，因为他是扮演托尼·克利夫顿的安迪·考夫曼，在扮演路易·德帕尔马的兄弟。
Jesus. Oh my God. So it's, it's a disaster. It sounds exhausting. But wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, there's more. So he's got to get fired. So get this. He's got to get fired.
天哪。哦，天哪。所以，这是一个灾难。听起来筋疲力尽。但是等等，等等，等等，等等，还有呢。所以他得被解雇。听着这个。他得被解雇。
Cause I call Ed Weinberger down. I say, you got to see the scene. So he comes down. He's got to get, we got to, we have to fire. You have to fire Tony Clifton. Right. We have to fire Tony Clifton. And then, so we call George Shapiro, Andy's manager.
因为我把埃德·温伯格叫下来。我说，你得来看看这场戏。所以他下来了。他得被，我们得，我们必须解雇。你必须解雇托尼·克利夫顿。对。我们必须解雇托尼·克利夫顿。然后，所以我们打电话给乔治·夏皮罗，安迪的经纪人。
He says, Tony's not going to be happy. So Ed gets a call that we have to fire Tony, Tony slash Andy the next day. And he wants to be fired in front of the entire cast. With a prostitute on each knee. If you're going to fire me, you're going to talk to them too. So we come down the next day. There's a prostitute on each knee.
他说，托尼不会高兴的。所以埃德接到电话说我们第二天必须解雇托尼，托尼slash安迪。而且他想在全体演员面前被解雇。两边膝盖上各坐一个妓女。如果你要解雇我，你得也跟他们谈谈。所以我们第二天下来了。两边膝盖上各坐着一个妓女。
Tony, Tony Danza has a camera as an eight millimeter. And Ed comes down and he says, you're fired. And Tony says, I'm not to leave it. And said, you're fired. He says, I'm not leaving. So meanwhile, I'm watching Tony, Tony filming. And I'm standing with Judd and Jeff Conaway. And Jeff Conaway says, I want to go, I'm going out there.
托尼，托尼·丹扎拿着一台8毫米摄像机。埃德下来对他说，你被解雇了。托尼说，我才不走。埃德说，你被解雇了。他说，我不走。与此同时，我在看着托尼，托尼在拍摄。我和贾德还有杰夫·康纳威站在一起。杰夫·康纳威说，我要过去，我要去干他妈的。
I'm going to fucking kill him. Yeah. And both of us, Tony and I grabbed Conaway and say, just let this play out. Just, just let this play out. And Ed says, you're fired. He says, I'm not going. And Judd says, okay, I'm going to play.
是啊。我们俩，托尼和我拉住康纳威说，就让这事顺其自然吧。就，就让这事顺其自然吧。埃德说，你被解雇了。他说，我不走。贾德说，好吧，我来。
So Judd goes out there and literally picks him up, takes him off the stage. And he's screaming, you know, like this. And then we hire another actor, Richard Ferange, to play Tony's, to play Danny's brother. We shoot the show the next week. And he comes in as if nothing happened. That's absolutely lord.
所以贾德走过去，字面意思上把他抱起来，把他弄出了舞台。他还在尖叫，你知道，就像这样。然后我们雇了另一个演员理查德·弗兰吉来扮演托尼的，扮演丹尼的兄弟。我们在第二周拍摄了这集。而他走进来，就好像什么都没发生过一样。绝对是大佬。
But that was him. He got his nachos that way. I know, but that's so, but if it wasn't for like, if it wasn't filmed, what's the payoff? It's just something he wanted to do. I mean, Sean, he kept a shift at Greenblatt's deli while he was on the show.
但这就是他。他就是用那种方式得到他想要的。我知道，但这也太，如果不是被拍下来，回报是什么？这只是他想做的事。我是说，肖恩，他在节目期间还在格林布拉特熟食店留了一个排班。
I'm not kidding. Yeah. It's a bust point. Yeah. Jimmy, was he, what was he like behind the cameras? When you guys, did Andy ever just kind of get real with you and kind of get you, let you in on the joke? Or did he just kind of stay?
我没开玩笑。是啊。是个公交站点。是啊。吉米，他是，他在镜头后面是什么样的？当你们，安迪有没有对你展现真实的一面，让你加入到这个恶作剧里？还是他一直保持那样？
Never got in on a joke. Never did that, but there were, there was the party, the wrap party after that at Ed's house at the end of the season when Andy showed up and Conaway was still mad. And so I said to Andy, come with me, follow me, we'll go to my house. So I went to my house and he had a date and I was married then.
从来没有加入过恶作剧。从来没有那样，但有过，季末在埃德家有一场派对，庆功派对，当时安迪出现了，而康纳威依然很生气。所以我对安迪说，跟我来，跟着我，我们去我家。所以我去了我家，他带了个女伴，我当时结婚了。
And I talked to him. He was, he's a rich kid, he was a rich kid from Great Neck Long Island. Wow. Yeah. And I said, what goes on? He says, I just, yeah, he says, that's how I think. That's what I want to do. He was, that was, that was, if you ever saw his act,
我和他谈了谈。他是个，他是个富家子弟，他是长岛大颈的富家子弟。哇。是啊。我说，这到底是怎么回事？他说，我只是，是啊，他说，我就是这么想的。这就是我想做的。他当时，那是，如果你看过他的表演，
he had that mechanic suit on. He did, you know, the Mighty Mouse theme. Yeah. You know, or he would lip sync. Here I come to say today, he did that. He did, he wrestled women. He was the best Elvis impersonator you've ever seen. Yeah.
他穿着那个机械师的工作服。他做了，你知道的，大力鼠的主题曲。是啊。你知道，或者他会假唱。我来拯救世界了，他做了那个。他跟女人摔跤。他是我见过最棒的猫王模仿者。是啊。
Didn't he get in the fight with Letterman once or something? Yeah. He may have. There's a great documentary on him. I know. Which one? I'm not sure what it's called, but I saw one. Not the Jim Carrey one, right?
他不是有一次跟莱特曼打过架还是怎么着？是啊。他可能打过。有一部关于他的很棒的纪录片。我知道。哪一部？我不太记得叫什么名字了，但我看过一部。不是金·凯瑞那部，对吧？
The Jim Carrey one. No, no, that movie is incredible, but there's like this documentary I saw. And I feel like that Ted Danza footage was in it somehow. No, Tony never found it. No. Well, there was some great stuff on the set of Taxi though, for sure.
金·凯瑞那部。不，不，那部电影太棒了，但还有一部我看过的纪录片。我觉得特德·丹扎的那些影像资料不知怎么就在里面。不，托尼从没发现。不。好吧，《出租车》片场确实有一些很棒的素材。
Yeah. Jimmy, tell us why you wrote this book. What was, I'll bet you resisted for a long time. Somebody finally beat you down and you told all these great stories. What do you hope the reader will get from it, aside from lots of laughter? So you got my text talk about the book?
是啊。吉米，告诉我们你为什么要写这本书。什么是，我敢说你抗拒了很长一段时间。最后终于有人把你磨得没脾气了，然后你讲了所有这些精彩的故事。除了带来很多欢笑之外，你希望读者能从中得到什么？所以你收到我谈论这本书的短信了？
Yeah. No, but I'm curious myself. No, I can't wait to read it. Well, the number one person who made me write the book was my wife, Debbie. Love. She said, you're sitting at home like a slouch. It's COVID.
是啊。不，不过我也很好奇。不，我迫不及待想读了。好吧，逼我写这本书的第一号人物是我妻子黛比。亲爱的。她说，你就像个懒汉一样坐在家里。现在是新冠疫情期间。
Put these stories down somewhere. So I got a, I called my agency and they put me in touch with a literary guy who had just written the Mel Brooks book, a guy named Eddie Freefeld, who's a big fan of comedy. And I started telling stories. And I have so many of them, which is one of the reasons Dad made me write the book. I just, you know, she said, you got to get those stories out
把这些故事写在某个地方吧。所以我找了，我给我的经纪公司打了电话，他们把我介绍给了一个刚写完梅尔·布鲁克斯书的文学界人士，一个叫埃迪·弗里费尔德的家伙，他是喜剧的超级粉丝。我开始讲故事。我有很多故事，这也是爸爸逼我写这本书的原因之一。我只是，你知道，她说，你得把这些故事讲出来。
there. Did you start remembering stories that you didn't even know we're still in your head? I'll bet so. Yeah. They start triggering other things, you know. Once you tell a story and then your memory story, and then you think of a person, your memory stuff.
你开始记起那些你甚至不知道还留在脑海里的故事了吗？我敢说会的。是啊。它们开始触发其他事情，你知道的。一旦你讲了一个故事，然后是你的记忆故事，然后你想到一个人，你的记忆内容。
And so it's, you know, it became a little bit about me growing up and a little bit about my dad, mostly about the shows I've done and the shows I've done and the incredible amount of fun I've had working with actors, especially like you guys. You know, you put all these great characters in people's living rooms for so many years to the point where they kind of have become family members for so many people around the world, not just in
所以这，你知道，它变得有点关于我成长经历，一点关于我父亲，主要关于我做过的节目，以及我和演员们一起工作，尤其是像你们这样的演员，所获得的难以置信的无穷乐趣。你知道，你把所有这些伟大的角色放进人们的起居室很多年，以至于他们对于全世界，不仅仅是在美国的许多人来说，在某种程度上已经成为了家庭成员。
America. So I bet it would be fascinating for these people to actually basically learn the birth story of all of these favorite family members that they have. By the way, I want to learn about. I like, I can't wait. Well, yeah, we all, and we all, like everybody out there, we all have relationships with these shows.
所以我敢打赌，对这些人来说，去了解他们所有的这些最喜欢的家庭成员的诞生故事，一定会非常着迷。顺便说一句，我想了解。我喜欢，我迫不及待了。好吧，是的，我们所有人，还有我们所有人，就像外面的每个人一样，我们都与这些节目有着某种联系。
And for us, it triggers emotions of that time in our life. Cheers because it was on for nearly a decade or a decade. It reminds me of, it reminds me of my grandmother who watched every episode of Cheers. It reminds me of my buddies. It reminds me of us when we were teenagers and quoting it on Friday morning after a Thursday night and some great thing. And it played such a huge life.
对我们来说，它触发了我们生命中那个时期的情感。因为《干杯酒吧》播出了将近十年或十年。它让我想起，它让我想起我的祖母，她看《干杯酒吧》的每一集。它让我想起我的哥们儿。它让我想起我们还是青少年的时候，在周四晚上之后的周五早上引用里面的台词，讨论一些精彩的内容。它在生活中扮演了如此巨大的角色。
I, I quote all the time, one of the funniest scenes I've ever seen in a television program or a movie ever. It just always makes me laugh is that scene where Diane says, Shelley Long goes, I'm leaving and I'm never coming back. This is the last you'll ever see. And she walks out, right? So I was like, huh, they're kind of stunned. And then all of a sudden the door cracks open just a little
我，我一直在引用，这是我在电视节目或电影中看过最搞笑的场景之一。它总是让我笑个不停，那就是黛安说的那场戏，谢莉·朗说，我要走了，再也不回来了。这是你最后一次见到我。然后她走出去了，对吧？所以我当时想，哈，他们有点惊呆了。然后突然门裂开了一条缝
bit. And you see her hand come in and she's reaching for the coat rack because she forgot her coat. And, and Rhea Perlman, Carla, she notices that this is happening. So she's standing next to the coat rack. So then she just pulls the coat rack just out of reach of the hand till finally the point Diane comes in because she's got
你能看到她的手伸进来，她在抓衣帽架，因为她忘了拿外套。而雷·普尔曼，卡拉，她注意到这正在发生。所以她站在衣帽架旁边。然后她就把衣帽架往后拉，刚好拉到那只手够不着的地方，直到最后黛安因为她必须拿外套，
to get her coat. She steps back inside to grab her coat. At which point Carla goes, Hey, everybody, look, it's Diane. To me, it's like such a perfect comedy moment. I talk about it all the time. So clean. How often do you talk to those folks anymore? Really, any of the cast members from any of these shows,
她重新走进来拿外套。这时卡拉说，嘿，大家快看，是黛安。对我来说，这简直是一个完美的喜剧时刻。我一直在谈论它。太干净了。你现在多久和那些老朋友聊一次天？真的，任何这些节目的演员，
any of these careers you've made are aside from us three idiots, how often do you get to visit with some of these great folks? I see, I see Jen, you know, frequently. Well, I don't frequently, you know, for her frequently twice a year. Yeah. And I see swimmer when I can.
你成就的这些职业生涯中，除了我们三个笨蛋，你多久能和这些优秀的人聚一次？我看到，我看到珍，你知道，挺频繁的。好吧，我也不算频繁，你知道，对她来说频繁就是一年两次。是啊。我一有机会就会见施维默。
Yeah. And LeBlanc and Teddy and. Teddy Danson. They're all such great people too. I mean, you know, I bet working with you helped because a lot of these people found enormous success and careers under your tutelage. They're very lucky.
是啊。还有勒布朗、特德和。特德·丹森。他们也都是非常棒的人。我是说，你知道，我敢说跟你合作有很大帮助，因为这些人很多都在你的悉心指导下取得了巨大的成功和职业生涯。他们很幸运。
I count myself as one of these people. Although my, my, my, my career was stumbling for many years, but being able to work with and for somebody like you who had just such an ease with so many people made it seem so fun, so comfortable, you know, kept us from, you know, having our heads blow up or, or, I mean, I just, the greatest note you ever gave me was, you know, stop pushing, you know, like I, I could have just, you know, taken.
我把自己也算作这些人之一。尽管我的，我的，我的职业生涯磕磕绊绊了好多年，但能够和像你这样的人一起工作并为你工作，你对那么多人都那么随和，让这一切看起来如此有趣、如此舒适，你知道，让我们没有飘飘然，或者，我是说，我只是，你给过我最棒的评价是，你知道，别太刻意了，你知道，就像我本来可以，你知道，随心所欲。
Dying for you to take it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. To jump on that, Jimmy, you know, I've, I've always said to you that, you know, you're such a father figure to me. I don't know if you heard, I never had one, but I've learned. Well, you did.
迫不及待想看你随心所欲了。是啊。是啊。是啊。顺着这个说下去，吉米，你知道，我，我一直对你说，你知道，你对我就像父亲一样。我不知道你有没有听说，我从来没有过父亲，但我学到了。好吧，你确实有。
No, you didn't have one. He just ran away. He took off. Car and gear and just get it. Yeah. Once he got to know you, he split. Well, Jimmy's the dad that stayed, but I've learned so much from you over the years, not only about comedy, obviously, but
不，你没有。他直接跑了。开着车一溜烟跑了。是啊。一旦他了解了你，他就溜了。好吧，吉米是那个留下来了的爸爸，但我这些年从你身上学到了太多，不仅是关于喜剧，显然还有
about the business, about storytelling, about relationships, about communication, about finances, about respect and so many other things. And I never had that in my whole life. Being a good leader on set too. Yeah, for sure. For sure. I remember, Jimmy, you don't remember this probably, but the
关于这个行业，关于讲故事，关于人际关系，关于沟通，关于财务，关于尊重以及其他许许多多的事情。我一辈子都没得到过这些。在片场也要做一个好领导。是啊，绝对的。绝对的。我记得，吉米，你可能不记得了，但
first time I ever actually met you, I was with Jason. We were in New York. You were there for the upfronts. And we, we stopped on the street. We were on Fifth Avenue. We were talking for a second in there. We said, all right, see you later. And I said to you, all right, cheers.
我真正第一次见到你，我和杰森在一起。我们在纽约。你当时在那里参加电视网推介会。我们，我们在街上停了下来。我们在第五大道。我们在那儿聊了一会儿。我们说，好的，回头见。我对你说，好的，干杯。
Just as like a sort of like, you know, you use the term cheers. Typical Canadian. Jimmy, you walked away and Jason was paused there with that look, you know, that Bateman look on his face, kind of similar to his face right now. He just goes, fucking cheers, man, to Jimmy Burroughs. What are you, an idiot? And I go, I didn't even, I didn't even, I swear to God.
就好像是一种，你知道，你用了“干杯”这个词。典型的加拿大人。吉米，你走开了，而杰森留在那里，脸上带着那种表情，你知道，他那张贝特曼式的表情，有点类似于他现在的表情。他只是说，真他妈干杯啊，老兄，对吉米·伯罗斯说。你是个白痴吗？我说，我甚至都没，我甚至都没，我向上帝发誓。
We'd always, we'd always go, we'd always, if we were at a dinner, we'd always have our glasses with Jimmy and whatever it was. Somebody, somebody inevitably to go cheers. He'd go, Will and Grace. Hey, to friends, huh? Yeah. Anyway, Jimmy, thank you for being here, my dear. You're very sweet to join us.
我们总是，我们总是，如果我们一起吃晚餐，我们总是和吉米一起举起杯子，无论那是什么。总会有人不由自主地喊一句干杯。他会说，威尔与格蕾丝。嘿，为了老友，哈？是啊。无论如何，吉米，谢谢你来到这里，亲爱的。你能加入我们真是太好了。
Three of my favorite people. You're our favorite. Jimmy, we love you. Love you so much. We love you too. I still have my favorite photograph I have in my house. It's just you taking at some wedding somewhere. You just looking right into camera.
我最喜欢的三个。你是我们的最爱。吉米，我们爱你。非常爱你。我们也爱你。我家里仍然挂着我最喜欢的一张照片。那是你在某场婚礼上的照片。你正看着镜头。
No expression. No, nothing. Just a big white finger, middle finger. Right there. Can you see it? Right there. Oh yeah, there it is. Yeah.
没有表情。什么都没有。只有一根巨大的白色手指，中指。就在那儿。你能看见吗？就在那儿。哦，对，就是那个。是啊。
It was Amy Peach's wedding. That's right. That's right. Carolina in the city. Another baby you born. Wait, wait. I've also got to remind, just remind me of this, to be the greatest direction I've ever heard you give anybody.
那是艾米·皮奇的婚礼。没错。没错。城市里的卡罗莱纳。你孕育的另一个宝贝。等等，等等。我还得提醒，只需提醒我这个，你给任何人的最棒的导演指导。
We were rehearsing a scene once and you said to somebody, as we're going, moving from one scene over to the next scene, you're wheeling your podium. And you go to this person, you go, hey, clear around the lines. And they said, which ones? And you said, all of them. One of the pieces of directions I got one time, Jimmy was really sick one week, like really sick.
我们有一次在排练一场戏，你对某个人说，当我们从一个场景过渡到下一个场景时，你推着你的演讲台。你对这个人说，嘿，清理掉所有的台词。他们说，哪几句？你说，所有的。我得到过最好的指导之一，吉米有一次病得很重，非常重。
And you still showed up to work and you're still working. And I was like being annoying, my annoying self. And I was like, Jimmy, I think it's funny if I do, you know, if I jump on the couch here and I go, what do you think if I just ran over here and then exit the door? And you said, honey, I don't care. And I ended up doing some stupid shit. And then you were better.
而你依然来上班，依然在工作。而我就像个烦人精一样，做我那个烦人的自己。我说，吉米，如果我这么做，你知道，如果我在这里跳上沙发，然后说，如果我跑到这里然后从门口出去，你觉得怎么样？你说，亲爱的，我不在乎。结果我做了一些蠢事。然后你病好了。
You got better like the next day or two days after you're like, what are you doing? The best. When I was doing Mike and Molly, I had a scene with Melissa and Billy and Reno. And Billy and Reno were on either side of Melissa and Melissa was listening. And they weren't, the dialogue wasn't making any sense to the character of Molly. So I said, why don't you kind of get up and walk away?
你在一天或两天后病好了，你说，你在干什么？最棒的。我在拍《迈克和莫莉》时，我和梅利莎、比利还有雷诺有一场戏。比利和雷诺在梅利莎的两侧，而梅利莎在听。他们没有，台词对莫莉这个角色来说毫无意义。所以我说，你为什么不站起来走开呢？
They probably won't even notice. And so she did. And then in the run through, the writers said, we would rather have her at the table. So I said, okay, and Melissa said, what should I do? I said, walk away in your mind. Yeah. I'll bet she did.
他们可能甚至都不会注意到。所以她照做了。然后在彩排中，编剧说，我们宁愿让她坐在桌子旁。所以我说，好吧，梅利莎问，我该怎么做？我说，在心里走开。是啊。我敢说她照做了。
Yeah. She did. And she sent me a blanket with walk away in your mind. Embroidery. Walk away. That's hysterical. Jimmy, you're the king. No, you guys are the king.
是啊。她照做了。她送给我一条印着“在心里走开”的毯子。刺绣的。走开。太爆笑了。吉米，你才是王。不，你们才是王。
Thank you. We love you, Pally. We love you. Give Deb a big hug, please. Thank you for doing this. You can slam your laptop shut if you want. No. Okay. Sean, what a girl.
谢谢。我们爱你，老伙计。我们爱你。请给黛比一个大大的拥抱。谢谢你做这一切。如果你想的话，你可以把笔记本电脑合上。不。好吧。肖恩，真是个女孩。
Isn't that great? I was so excited because I knew you guys would be so thrilled and we all know him and love him. And you had no idea that he was coming? No idea. I got the email today too, right about his book, about the book party. Yes, for his book. And so I was just looking at it when I got home right before we started doing the podcast today. I was looking at it.
这不是太棒了吗？我太兴奋了，因为我知道你们会超级激动，而且我们都认识他、爱戴他。你根本不知道他要来？完全不知道。我今天也收到了电子邮件，关于他的书，关于新书派对的。是的，为了他的书。所以当我今天回家，在我们开始录播客之前，我正看着它。我当时正在看。
I was just reading the email before I got in and we started talking about Jason before he got on. And then I was like, oh my God, they have the books coming out. I'm so happy and Jimmy and I miss him. And then there he is. I just love that man so much. I wanted to be, I wanted to be Jimmy Burroughs so bad. You still can. I was on my way. I was trying so hard. I was shadowing him. I was watching him directly.
我甚至在上线前还在看邮件，我们在杰森上线前开始谈论他。然后我就想，哦，天哪，他们的书要出版了。我太高兴了，吉米和我错过了他。然后他就出现在那儿了。我太爱那个男人了。我曾想成为，我太想成为吉米·伯罗斯了。你现在还可以。我正在路上了。我那么努力。我在模仿他。我在直接观察他。
Do you remember when we did, when I came on to guest on Will and Grace and I was staying Jason at your old house. And I stayed with you and Amanda. By the way, I never thanked you. Thank you. It was a while ago. No, no, no. It's never too late to say thanks. But I went and when I rehearsed all week and then tape night, you came to the tape night and you stood down on the floor with Jimmy and you shadowed him while we were doing the taping. Do you remember that? Absolutely remember that.
你还记得我们做的时候吗，当我作为嘉宾去客串《威尔与格蕾丝》时，我住在杰森你以前的家里。我和你还有阿曼达住在一起。顺便说一句，我从没谢过你。谢谢你。那是好久以前的事了。不，不，不。说谢谢永远不会太迟。但我去了，当我排练了一整周然后在录制之夜，你来到录制现场，站在地板上和吉米在一起，我们在录制时你一直在模仿他。你还记得吗？当然记得。
I wanted it so bad. And then acting got in the way. And here I am. He's a lovely man. Everything I know about this business is because of him, basically. Think about the show. He rattles him off. So we go Mary, Tyler Moore, Taxi.
我太渴望那个了。然后演戏挡了道。而我留在了这里。他是个可爱的家伙。关于这个行业我所知道的一切基本上都是因为他。想想那部剧。他如数家珍。所以我们有《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀》、《出租车》。
Then every episode of Cheers, Frasier, every episode of Will and Grace does the pilots of Friends in a bunch of the first season. Sorry if I'm missing. No, you're right. Keep going. Big bang theory. Two and a half men. Big bang theory. Two and a half men. All these great sitcoms, multi-camera shows. Yeah. And a lot of them he directed every episode.
然后《欢乐酒店》、《费城永远阳光灿烂》的每一集，《威尔与格蕾丝》的每一集，都在第一季的很多集中模仿了《老友记》试播集。抱歉如果我漏掉了。不，你是对的。继续。生活大爆炸。好汉两个半。生活大爆炸。好汉两个半。所有这些伟大的情景喜剧，多机位节目。是的。而且其中很多节目他都执导了每一集。
I know. It's crazy. Where the hell is that format now? I just, I still don't get it. I think we talked about it. I think it's because networks don't bet on just, you have to bet on one to keep it on like they did with Cheers. Like they do with a lot of shows. We just, or Seinfeld, right? You just have to like pick one guys at any of the networks that you like and keep it on the air no matter what.
我知道。这太疯狂了。那个模式现在到底在哪里？我只是，我还是不明白。我想我们谈过这个。我想这是因为电视台不愿只是押注，你必须押注其中一个来维持它，就像他们对《欢乐酒店》做的那样。就像他们对很多节目做的那样。我们只是，或者《宋飞正传》，对吧？你只需要在任何电视台挑一个你喜欢的家伙，不管怎样都要让它在电视上播出。
Let me ask you this too. Are there any multi-cam writers out there who are interested in doing that? Do you think that that's a kind of dying art in that way? I bet a lot of them have definitely gotten rusty probably, but I mean, I think it's, I'm not saying that it's an easy thing to do because it's not. But there is a formula to it. I mean, it is set up, set up joke and you get a great group of people together in a room. You can find a rhythm. I don't think that's, I think that the networks are just feeling like the audiences wouldn't watch and I would, I would say that.
我也想问你这个。有没有什么多机位编剧有兴趣做这个？你认为这在某种程度上是一门正在消亡的艺术吗？我敢打赌他们很多人肯定都生疏了，但是，我的意思是，我认为这，我并不是说这是一件容易的事，因为事实并非如此。但它有一个公式。我的意思是，它是建立，建立笑话，你把一群优秀的人聚在一个房间里。你可以找到节奏。我不认为这是，我认为电视台只是觉得观众不会看，我会说。
If it was good, I would watch the fuck out of it. But I mean, even if it isn't good, I think just people's attention spans are even smaller now than they were back then. Like never more have you needed something that's only 22 minutes long, you know? Right. And that you don't have to pay too much attention to that you can just kind of listen like he said, like the radio, the rhythm of it. Playing as people say, like, I like a show that's just kind of playing in the background. These are perfect. Well, I know the three of us, we've threatened, we've talked about doing it in the past.
如果它很好看，我他妈的肯定会看。但我的意思是，即使它不好看，我想现在人们的注意力持续时间甚至比以前更短了。就像你从来没有比现在更需要一个只有22分钟长的节目，你知道吗？对的。而且你不需要太注意，你可以就像他说的，像收音机一样听，它的节奏。正如人们所说，我喜欢一个只是在背景里播放的节目。这些都很完美。好吧，我知道我们三个人，我们曾经威胁过，我们过去谈过要做这件事。
We can say that. And we keep going like about, what is it about every three months? The three of us looking each other go, let's do a multi-cam, right? Yeah. And then we're like, no, American. We're gonna side bar after this and do another one. Yeah. We're gonna another talk about it.
我们可以这么说。我们一直在讨论，大概每三个月一次？我们三个人看着对方说，我们做一个多机位剧吧，对吧？是的。然后我们就像，不，美国人。我们待会儿要在旁边讨论并再做一个。是的。我们要再讨论一下。
Well, what if it wasn't on every week? What if it was on every other week? Oh, here it comes. Here it comes. Here's the new pitch. Hi, wee. Smart. Nice.
好吧，如果不是每周播一次呢？如果是每两周播一次呢？哦，它来了。它来了。新的提案来了。嗨，微。聪明。不错。
Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice.
聪明。不错。聪明。不错。聪明。不错。聪明。不错。
Smart. Nice. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。不错。SmartLess 是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾尔和本内特·巴巴科 100% 有机且手工制作的。聪明。不错。聪明。不错。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。